>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> John Cole: Good
morning, good morning.
Welcome, welcome to the
National Book Festival.
I'm John Cole.
I'm the director of the Center for
the Book in the Library of Congress.
And it's my -- thank you, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: It is my
pleasure to scream at you.
[ Ringing ]
>> John Cole: That was a joke.
You can hear me now.
We're very pleased to have you here.
This is the 10th year of
the National Book Festival.
We know you're going to have
a wonderful day here today.
I want you to know that today,
that our one-hour performance here
about the Exquisite Corpse
Adventure is being filmed
for the Library's Web
site and for the archives,
and you'll have a chance to I hope,
ask some questions
and also participate.
And we want you to be mindful of
the fact that we have camera risers
in the back that cannot be tampered
with, or please don't sit on them.
And also, be careful when you speak,
you are going to be
recorded as well.
But we think you'll enjoy it
and you'll enjoy the experience.
What I have here to demonstrate is
the Exquisite Corpse new poster,
which is available in the back.
We hope everyone will
take it and remember
that this is a very
wonderful adventure story
that graphically is
going to be demonstrated
by our two artists today.
And also you're in for a real treat,
because towards the end of this,
you're going to see episode
number 27, which was written
by our Young People's National
Ambassador, Katherine Paterson,
and it will be a very
special treat for all of you.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: I want
to begin by recognizing
that this is the 10th
year of the partnership
between the National Children's
Book and Literacy Alliance
and the Center for the Book.
And it has been a fruitful
10-year partnership,
which has brought us not only
the Exquisite Corpse Adventure,
but this wonderful group of writers
that are going to be introduced
to you by Mary Brigid Barrett, who
is the President and the Founder,
and with Katherine
Paterson, a leading life
in the National Children's
Book and Literacy Alliance.
I'm pleased to turn this
over to Mary Brigid.
Mary Brigid?
>> Mary Brigid: Thank you, John.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary Brigid: Good
morning, Washington.
I am Mary Brigid Barrett,
and I'm the President
of the National Children's
Book and Literacy Alliance.
And on behalf of the NCBLA Board
of Authors and Illustrators,
I welcome you to the
Exquisite Corpse Adventure.
And we'd like to thank
Dr. Billington, Dr. Cole,
and the incredibly dedicated
staff of the Library of Congress
for inviting us to be here today.
Yeah, that's great.
I have a little housekeeping detail.
Everybody should have a program.
If you don't have a
program, raise your hand.
And there's going to be a reason
that you need the program,
so volunteers are going to --
keep your hands up 'til a
volunteer gets you a program.
And in this program, you're going
to find all kinds of information
about the Exquisite
Corpse Adventure,
what a progressive story is.
And there's information
about our amazing cast
of authors and illustrators.
And also there is a schedule
in the back that tells you
when our authors will be doing
their individual presentations
later today.
As John -- I don't know,
John didn't mention this,
but the Exquisite Corpse Adventure
has been read all year round
by literally thousands
of students and kids
around the United States
and around the world.
We have readers from
South Africa and Japan.
We have readers for
the Exquisite Corpse
that are reading the story
on Read.gov in Europe.
So it's been very exciting for us.
And on top of that,
teachers and librarians
and parents are using the
Exquisite Corpse with all
of the educational materials, and
they're getting the young people
in their lives reading more
and writing themselves,
which we think is really important.
So it's our deepest hope today
that this presentation inspires all
of you -- kids, moms,
dads and teachers --
to read the Exquisite Corpse if you
haven't read it on Read.gov yet,
and play the progressive
story game yourself.
You know, at home when you're
all wrapped up in the blankets
in winter, you can
share stories together
on those really long car trips when
you're about to kill each other
in the car -- that's when you want
to share those stories together.
And it's important to
write your own stories
and share them with people you love.
And I am really pleased
to announce today
that the Exquisite Corps Adventure
is going to be made into a book.
And it will be published
next fall by Candle of Press,
right in time for next
year's book festival.
And all of our authors
on stage, coincidentally,
are also contributors to
this incredible anthology
that the NCBLA put together
about our White House connecting
literacy to historical literacy.
It's won every award
imaginable in the last year,
and it has a brand new piece
at the end of it written
by poet Nikki Grimes about
her experience coming
to the historic inauguration
of President Obama,
which is the new edition
that updates the book,
the new piece that updates the book.
So make sure that you find this.
And when our authors are
illustrating between noon
and 1 o'clock, they have
also very graciously said
that they will sign copies of
our White House, if you want them
to sign that besides
their own terrific books.
Now, those programs that you all
have, open them up to the inside
and if you have a red
star inside your program,
you have just won your own
copy of our White House,
Looking in Looking out,
and where are the books --
are over there in the corner.
If you will take your program.
At the end of the presentation,
you take your program,
and you will get a free book with --
thank you Candle of Press
for providing free books
for our guests today.
>> John Cole: Mary Brigid?
>> Mary Brigid: Yes?
>> John Cole: Whenever
you have a chance,
I need to acknowledge the
kids while we're here.
Can I do it now?
>> Mary Brigid: Okay.
John wants to talk about some
of the wonderful kids
in the audience today.
>> John Cole: I want to give a
special welcome to four classes,
schools who are with us today.
They're brought here by the Old
Dominion Chapter of the Links.
We are very pleased to welcome
kids, and I want to hear from them.
When I mention your school, West
Gate Elementary from Manassas.
[ Cheering ]
>> John Cole: Stonewall
Middle School of Manassas.
[ Cheering ]
>> John Cole: Goodwin
Military Middle School --
not military -- Woodbridge.
[ Cheering ]
>> John Cole: And the C. D. Hylton
Senior High School in Woodbridge.
Welcome to all of you.
[ Cheering ]
>> Mary Brigid: Thank you, John.
Okay. One more item of business.
Later on in the program
as John told you,
we are going to have a
wonderful dramatic presentation.
But we need your help.
Gerry, our wonderful assistant here,
is going to be holding up two signs.
Can you show the signs?
And you can read the signs.
You don't have to react now,
but when she holds up one
of these signs, make sure you
do what it says on the sign.
It's your cue to help
us with the drama.
Okay. Finally, it's the time
to introduce our wonderful
authors and illustrators.
From the great state
of Massachusetts,
illustrator Timothy Basil Ering.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary Brigid: Next to him,
resplendent in her beautiful blue,
hailing from Rochester, New
York, is author Linda Sue Park.
[ Cheering ]
>> Mary Brigid: To your left zooming
down from the beautiful Hudson River
Valley, illustrator James Ransome.
[ Cheering ]
>> Mary Brigid: From the
cradle of democracy, Boston,
Massachusetts, M.T. Tobin Anderson.
[ Cheering ]
>> Mary Brigid: And last but
not least, traveling all the way
from the beautiful mountains in the
gorgeous state of Vermont, our hero,
a reading champion, our
nation's fairy grandmother,
United States National Ambassador
for Young People's
Literature, Katherine Paterson.
[ Cheering ]
>> Mary Brigid: Now,
we realize that many
of you have not had the opportunity
to discover the Exquisite
Corpse Adventure on Read.gov.
And so we didn't want to just
jump into the last episode
without a little bit of a
summary to get you warmed
up for the dramatic performance.
So Mr. Anderson, would
you help me out?
>> M.T. Anderson: Is my mike on?
Okay. For those of you who have
not yet tasted the delights
of the Exquisite Corpse Adventure
>> We offer a summary of dangerous
exploits and daring deeds.
>> The long
>> M.T. Anderson: And
the short of it.
The Exquisite Corpse
Adventure, the story begins
with a train rushing
through the night.
Our heroes, Joe and
Nancy, orphaned twins.
>> Mary Brigid: Tobin, you and
I, we, we could be Joe and Nancy.
>> M.T. Anderson: You
want us to be the twins?
>> Mary Brigid: Yes.
>> M.T. Anderson: I'm always
having trouble thinking
of us as the same species.
[ Audience moans ]
>> Mary Brigid: Forget it.
Continue, Tobin Anderson.
>> M.T. Anderson: Our heroes, Joe
and Nancy, receive a birthday card
from their previously
presumed dead parents.
Their task, limb by limb they must
piece together the Exquisite Corpse,
a top secret robot, and rescue
their aforementioned parents
from certain oblivion, trapped
outside of space and time.
Bolstered in their quest by
a roller-skating, a pirate,
a talking pig -- are
you getting all this --
a pack of wolves, an elephant, a
door mouse, a misfortune teller,
and a bobble-headed robot, aided
by the mysterious red arrows
on their little toes,
a crystal ball,
and handy skills acquired growing
up in the Sick and Tired Circus,
lion taming, knife throwing
and trapeze flying --
still on board with me?
They travel into the woods under the
sea, up to the sky, back and forth
through time, fending off
hunger, fatigue, despair,
sibling separation,
poisoned meatballs,
electronic pitchforks,
lances and prods.
They battle a narcoleptic clown,
a pack of thieves and dozens
of tentacled Eggy-Thing alien
invaders who disguise themselves
as gorillas, monster wolves and
squid beasts, torturing others
with bad puns and lame yolks.
I hope you're getting all this.
Only our heroes, Nancy and
Joe Sloppy and the Sick
and Tired Circus stand
between those alien Eggy-Things
and world domination.
Because you know, a story's not
a story unless someone's trying
for world domination, we feel.
>> Mary Brigid: That was
a really long summary.
>> M.T. Anderson: You can do better?
Let's hear your shorter version.
>> Mary Brigid: All right,
ladies and gentleman,
I need a little help here?
Ready? Here we go.
Orphans no more, Nancy and Joe set
out to save their parents
and fight their foes.
They pieced together
the Exquisite Corpse,
fight invading aliens,
running and warped.
Will they triumph, we don't know.
But I'd lay good money
on Nancy and Joe.
[ Cheering ]
>> Mary Brigid: We have a
little commercial break.
I would like anyone in the
audience whose birthday is today,
and maybe even on stage whose
birthday is today, to stand up
and wave their hands
wildly in the air.
Hey, look, we got on.
>> Happy birthday
>> Mary Brigid: To you,
happy birthday to you,
happy birthday dear Jimmy,
and everyone else,
happy birthday to you.
[ Applause ]
>> I really appreciate that.
Thank you.
>> Mary Brigid: All right.
It's almost time to hear
the very last episode
of the Exquisite Corpse Adventure.
But first, like Nancy and Joe,
we have to assemble the Exquisite
Corpse, the top secret robot.
Over on our left, Gerry's going
to be putting the Corpse together,
and we're going to do it --
we're going to put the
authors to the test.
We have a little quiz show,
and if the authors could
get their bicycle horns and
[ Bicycle horn]
>> Mary Brigid: Not
through your mike --
Joe said not through your mike.
>> Oh, sorry.
>> Mary Brigid: Okay.
All set?
>> Mary Brigid, can
Gerry stand in front,
because this side can't see at all.
Can Mary Brigid stand
right in front here?
>> Mary Brigid: Oh,
can I stand in front?
>> Sorry, Gerry, Gerry stand.
>> Mary Brigid: Oh, Gerry,
can you stand in front?
Okay. Gerry's going to stand
in front, and we're going
to test these authors out on
their Exquisite Corpse Adventure
trivia knowledge.
>> James Ransome: 1-2.
>> Mary Brigid: Yes, all set, James?
>> James Ransome: Yes, 1-2.
>> Mary Brigid: Tobin,
who you doing?
>> M.T. Anderson: Start without me.
>> Mary Brigid: All right.
Everybody, here authors.
Here's the first question.
Question number 1 to
assemble the Exquisite Corpse.
What wiley evil character has Tim
Ering drawing and what happens
if Tim Ering drawing down there,
what wiley evil character has Tim
Ering drawing and what happens
when that character juggles,
bumbles and fumbles it?
[ Bicycle horn ]
>> Mary Brigid: Oh.
Is it you got the answer?
What happens when he juggles?
Who is it?
>> It's Boppo.
>> Mary Brigid: It's
Boppo, the evil clown.
And what happens when he juggles?
>> Oh, I don't know that part.
>> Mary Brigid: Oh.
[ Bicycle horn ]
>> Mary Brigid: Katherine Paterson?
>> Katherine Paterson:
He goes to sleep.
>> Mary Brigid: He goes
to sleep when he juggles.
Oh, great.
Do we have a body part up there?
Okay, question number 2.
Which of the twins is older?
Nancy or Joe?
[ Bicycle horn ]
>> Mary Brigid: Oh.
James?
>> James Ransome: Nancy.
>> Mary Brigid: Yes.
>> James Ransome: She's
as shocked as I am.
>> Mary Brigid: I know.
And how -- does anyone know how
much older Nancy is than Joe?
>> James Ransome: Two minutes.
>> Mary Brigid: Two minutes?
>> James Ransome: I don't know.
[ Bicycle horn ]
>> I thought it was 15.
>> Mary Brigid: 15 minutes.
No. Anyone else?
>> I think it's less than a minute.
I'll bet on less than a minute.
>> Mary Brigid: 90 seconds.
>> 90 seconds?
>> Oh.
>> Mary Brigid: Question 3.
The character in James Ransome
drawing takes Nancy and Joe to spy
on the conference of aliens,
where they see the aliens'
true shape for the first time.
Who is that character and
what is the alien's true name?
[ Bicycle horn ]
>> James Ransome: Hathi.
>> Mary Brigid: Hathi.
Did you draw Hathi?
>> James Ransome: No, I didn't.
Oh, -- you
>> Mary Brigid: That's okay.
>> James Ransome: No, today
I didn't draw him, but I
>> Oh, I thought you did.
I came in late, sorry.
>> Mary Brigid: Okay.
Question number 4.
Where did the twins find
Roberta, the robot's, legs?
>> The what?
>> Mary Brigid: Roberta the robot's
legs, where did the twins find them?
[ Bicycle horn ]
>> Mary Brigid: Linda was first.
>> Linda Sue Park: Under the sea.
>> Mary Brigid: No.
>> Oh, oh, oh.
[ Bicycle horn ]
>> They hopped down on the
cradle of sun, didn't they?
>> Mary Brigid: Yes, they were
clowns running through time.
>> Oh, that's right.
>> Wait a second, what was
>> The arms were on the sea.
>> What was on the chimney?
>> The arms.
Break a leg.
>> Mary Brigid: Question 5, when the
twins discover a gingerbread house
in the woods, starving Joe
runs to it as a source of food,
but Nancy tries to
hold them back, saying,
don't you remember the story?
What story is Nancy referring to?
[ Bicycle horn ]
>> Mary Brigid: James?
>> James Ransome: Hansel Gretel.
>> Mary Brigid: Yes.
I know everyone here has
read Hansel and Gretel.
Question 6, how does Joe battle
the squid to recover the lost key?
[ Bicycle horns ]
>> Mary Brigid: Oh, my gosh.
These national ambassadors
are so brilliant.
Yes, Katherine?
>> Katherine Paterson: I think I
go start on James and Linda Sue.
Arm wrestling.
>> Mary Brigid: Arm wrestling, yes.
This is the last question, Gerry.
Do we have it almost assembled?
>> Gerry: One more page.
>> Mary Brigid: The heart.
We need to give Roberta her heart.
When Roberta the Robot has
finally been completely assembled,
what last object do
Nancy and Joe need
to find before they can
rescue their parents?
Oh, no, it's that National
Ambassador again.
>> Wait, that was a
real timid squeak.
[ Laughter ]
>> Katherine Paterson: The last egg?
>> Mary Brigid: The
last, the last --
what last object do Nancy and Joe
need to find before they collect
[ Bicycle horn ]
>> Mary Brigid: Yes.
>> Katherine Paterson: I do know.
I did this thing, though.
The head, the head of the robot.
>> Mary Brigid: Oh,
no, guys, she's wrong.
The National Ambassador's wrong.
>> The Ambassador's wrong.
>> The heart.
>> The brain.
>> The heart
>> No.
>> Memory.
>> Do you want me to give you
>> Katherine Paterson: The door.
>> Mary Brigid: The door.
>> The door.
>> Mary Brigid: That's the door.
[ Bicycle horn ]
>> Mary Brigid: Yes.
Now, we have successfully assembled
the Exquisite Corpse, Roberta,
the top secret robot and the moment
we have been waiting for all year.
I met a teacher right in
front of the audience here,
who her class has been waiting all
year to hear this last final episode
of the Exquisite Corps Adventure.
The name of the title of the
last episode is Over Easy,
and it is written and now directed
as a stage play by
Katherine Paterson.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary Brigid: Tobin?
>> M.T. Anderson: All right.
On one side of the forest, a
train rushes through the night,
a train filled with lions
and elephants and clowns.
And on the other side of the
forest, leaping and frothing,
yellow and sticky,
hurling their unfried
and unfriendly splattering
cells through the underbrush,
a tide of mucusy monsters
storms into the world.
And gathering around a hut,
near a broken train trestle,
a few friends stand between
an invasion of raw eggs
and the fate of the world.
In a case like this,
there's no sunny side up.
>> Katherine Paterson: If you
have been following this adventure
as closely as the authors have
hoped, you will not be surprised
to know at this moment, a
supreme crisis, Nancy the brave,
the intelligent, the moral Nancy,
took charge of the situation.
>> First of all, Pirandello
must stop the train
and tell the ringmaster to set
the tent up as quickly as possible
with the large opening
facing the woods.
It's so the aliens will all
come rushing in after us.
>> We're going to be standing
in there, like waiting for them?
>> Good thinking, Nancy.
We should all go now and
help them set up the tent.
We can do it in that grassy
spot right beside the tracks.
There's no time to lose.
>> M.T. Anderson: Everyone, except
Genius Kelly, who was very speedy
when he chose, swung up on
Hathi, the Elephant's back,
and the great beast
raced towards the spot.
>> Katherine Paterson: The train had
barely shuttered to a stop when all
of the members of the circus
had been hustled off and led
by the shouts by the
ringmaster, went to work.
As you can imagine,
persons who belong
to a circus are well
practiced in setting up a tent
in expeditious manner, in less
time than it would take you to sing
"99 Bottles of Beer on the Wall"
followed by all four versus of
"The Star Spangled Banner"
(provided you know all four verses),
the Big Top was erected.
>> M.T. Anderson: With no time
to spare, however, indeed,
Hathi and the other friendly
pachyderms had barely hammered
down the last tent pole when
the invasion of Eggy-Things,
having cast off all their disguises,
came streaming through the woods
and slurped into the tent at such
a speed that our friends winced
at the schlap against the
canvas on the opposite side.
The ringmaster was
already on the job.
"Ladies, Gentlemen, gentle beasts,
and uh -- Super Ova," we have,
if a bit hastily, assembled for you
the greatest little show on earth."
>> "Forget the show on earth.
We want extraterrestrial jokes."
[ Audience booing ]
>> "Ah, of course, but ours are
old and tired and very earthly.
We need your help."
>> "Yes. Give us your
yolks, and (yuk, yuk),
the yolk will be on you, old woman.
After the yolks we will give you
our very specially imported brand
of salmonella.
You will die slowly and painfully,
which will be fun to see,
but we won't be able to linger long.
We have to spread our contagion
throughout the planet."
>> Katherine Paterson: With
these words of mucusy menace,
the Eggy-Things started across the
width of the tent toward our heroes.
>> "No, no.
Ve only vant da yolks."
The silly ova began laughing
and separating themselves,
the yellows from the whites.
"
>> "Toodle-oo.
>> "Be ready.
As soon as we stop yoking
around, slither hither.
We got a yob to do.
Yuk, yuk."
>> "Don't worry.
We're right behind you."
>> Katherine Paterson: "Not
bad for one so colorless.
But somehow, we expected
better from you yellows.
If the condemned prisoner can
request one last good smoke,
we'd like to go out with
one last good joke."
>> The eggy folks -- the eggy
yolks couldn't bear to be sneered
at by a pig and began to
scramble for the honor
of delivering the last good joke.
>> "Knock, knock."
>> "Who's there?"
>> "Oregon."
>> "Oregon who?"
>> "Ore-e-gonna take
over the world?"
>> "You betcha."
>> Katherine Paterson: The yuks
that followed this bad joke were
so loud they shook the tent.
[ Laughing ]
>> Katherine Paterson: But
to the invaders' distress,
not one of our heroes
even cracked a smile.
The yokes tried again.
>> "Knock, knock."
>> "Who's there?"
>> "Scieszka."
>> "Scieszka how?"
>> "Gesundheidt."
>> "No more shouting out answers."
>> M.T. Anderson: "I'm sorry.
But I do want to have one last
laugh before it's all over,
and I already heard that joke."
The yokes went into a huddle,
or for those readers familiar
with the game, into
sort of a rugby scrum.
At last one yoke seemed
to separate from the mass.
There was the sound
of a throat clearing.
>> "A hum.
We are going to have a yoke
-- we're going to have a joke
or if you prefer a yoke off.
The winner will have the honor
of making the final joke."
>> Katherine Paterson:
Genius Kelly sighed loudly
and pretended to examine his hoof.
The elephants sighed
even more loudly and lay
down on the ground and
pretended to snore.
>> "If you noodle noggins have
any desire to live long enough
for the last laugh, this
will be the last chance."
>> M. T. Anderson: With that he/she
or it ducked back into the scrum
and soon there arose from
that side of the tent
such a cacophony of
screeches and yuks
[ Screeches and yuks ]
>> M.T. Anderson: that our heroes
put their hands, hooves, paws,
feet or trunks over
their ears in defense.
>> "Look."
>> Katherine Paterson: Joe looked
and what he saw astounded him.
A mass of yellows was going
around faster and faster.
The more the yolks yelled,
the faster around they went.
The scrum was being scrambled.
[ Laughing ]
>> M.T. Anderson: "Those
stupid yokes are,
are beating themselves up."
Nancy glanced over at
the waiting egg whites.
If they had had eyes, their eyes
would have been popping out.
>> "Quick.
Everyone go into your act.
As fast as you can."
>> Katherine Paterson:
Suddenly, the Sick
and Tired Circus was
sick and tired no more.
Genius Kelly danced and whirled
into his magical judo act.
The twins did loopdy
loops on the high wires;
the elephants swung their trunks
about and then their huge rear ends
with their tails a-twirling.
The Ringmaster spun
around with his whip going
at least ninety miles per hour.
Roberta grabbed the hand
of the headless woman
who in turn grabbed a monkey's
paw that grabbed the hand
of the bearded woman who
grabbed a string of chimps
who grabbed a seal's flipper
who flapped Roberta's other hand
and they raced a ring a round a
rosie about the startled whites
who grew paler and fuller
of air by the moment.
>> M.T. Anderson: Every now
and then a piteous wail arose
over the racket of
frenzied circus acts.
>> "Help"
>> "Stop! I'm air sick!"
>> "We'll mend our wicked way
if you'll stop whipping us!"
>> Katherine Paterson: But
no one even paused to listen.
Our heroes knew better than to
trust even the pallid portion
of the villainous invaders.
And before long all the whites had
been whipped into a giant meringue,
making the lions roar with delight.
[ Roar ]
>> M.T. Anderson: "Fire
juggling act!"
The clowns grabbed the torches
and juggled and breathed fire
onto the newly whipped
meringue until it stood
up in beautiful ecru peaks.
>> "Mmmmm.
Scrambled eggs for the main course
and a lovely meringue for dessert.
It looks almost good enough to eat."
>> Katherine Paterson: "Almost."
>> M.T. Anderson: Meanwhile Angel
had been busy summoning the Cradle
of Time.
With the elephants' help all
the scrambled yolks were piled
into the cradle topped
off by the giant meringue.
>> Katherine Paterson: For a few
moments our exhausted friends
watched and listened, the beasts
panting, the people perspiring,
but they needn't have worried.
There wasn't even a
whimper from the cradle.
Neither the scrambled yolks nor
the whipped whites showed any sign
of reconstituting.
The Eggy-Things that had threatened
them for so long had been done
in by their own rotten
humor and the cleverness
of our little band of heroes.
>> "Now, off you go,
back to the big bang."
>> "Not so fast!"
>> Katherine Paterson: The ominous
but familiar voice belonged
of course, to Boppo.
[ Booing and hissing ]
>> Katherine Paterson: He had
one giant clown foot atop Libby
Verrie-Sloppy and another
holding Professor Alistair Sloppy
on the ground.
Both the twins' parents
appeared to be asleep.
>> "They're under my power.
While the rest of you were
busy whipping up trouble,
I managed to hypnotize this
pair with my best juggling at.
It was all done with mirrors -- very
skillfully, if I do say so myself.
Now, I will rescue my
comrades and throw these two
into the cradle of their own making.
Then I will extract one final
bomb from my pocket which will,
for sentimental reasons, go off
in exactly 47 ticks of the clock."
>> "Oh, no.
Not that stupid juggling act again."
>> "Just when I thought
misfortune had landed on its head."
>> "I never trusted
that red-nosed ruffian."
>> Katherine Paterson: "Oink."
>> "Huh?"
>> "Lullaby and goodnight."
>> "With roses bedight."
>> Katherine Paterson: Before
they got to the third line
about the lilies, Boppo had
sunk to the earth with a snore.
>> M.T. Anderson: With
catlike quickness,
Angel threw the evil clown and
his ticking bomb into the cradle
and sent him and the whole alien
brunch racing toward the creation
of the universe.
>> Katherine Paterson: It happened
so fast that they all simply stared
at the empty space in the sky
that the cradle had flown through.
>> "Hurray."
>> M.T. Anderson: Everyone
turned in amazement.
The tiny voice had
come from the throat
of the headless woman --
her first spoken word.
>> Katherine Paterson: A baby
monkey began to clap his tiny hands
and soon they were all cheering
and dancing and shouting
and hugging one another in
relief that the danger had passed
and in joy at what
they had accomplished.
[ Cheering ]
>> And now we come to the part
of the story no one likes much --
the farewells between friends who
have suffered and struggled and,
yes, even laughed together.
>> M.T. Anderson: Pirandello
headed off to the forest
where he found Orlando munching
on gummi bears and took her home.
Angel and Sybil said goodbye
and started off together,
as Angel had become quite fond of
the Misfortune Teller and determined
to protect her from any misfortunes
that still lurked in
her neighborhood.
>> Katherine Paterson: The last
departing pair were Roberta
and Genius Kelly.
Roberta had cleverly undone
Boppo's hypnotic spell
over the Senior Sloppys.
When their friends and
ours had escorted them
to the door before
Pirandello's shack,
the professor gave me
a lovely little speech,
thanking the robot handsomely
for all she had done,
and then adding, a big sadly:
>> "My dear, you are
no longer a corpse,
as exquisite as you were and are.
You are free to go back
to that other dimension
where you will find others of
your rare kind that I constructed
in my years behind the door.
They will welcome you as
the hero you have become.
Take this wonderful
pig back with you,
as he and you belong in
that other dimension.
He will serve as a companion and a
reminder of all you have both done
to save not only the sloppy family,
but all human and animal kind.
The key which you have you will
take back with you through the door.
Please lock it behind you
and throw it away, for,
though the Eggy-Things no
longer exist in that dimension
or in this one, I am convinced
that there should be no more
trafficking between our two worlds."
>> Katherine Paterson:
Genius Kelly opened his snout
to make a long speech, but Roberta
punched him on the short ribs
and smilingly urged him toward
the door, though she paused
on the threshold to
hug the twins and say:
>> "Now I know I have a
heart, because it's breaking."
>> Oh, man.
>> It was all Nancy could
do to keep from weeping.
Even brave Joe was seen
to wipe away a tear.
>> Katherine Paterson: "Wait!
I have to tell the
twins their true names."
>> "Nancy and Joe are
not our real names?"
>> Katherine Paterson: "No.
Your true names
[ Clears throat ]
>> Katherine Paterson: "are
Josephus and Natochka."
>> "What?"
>> "I'm sorry, children.
We repented as soon as we
filed the birth certificates."
>> "That's why we've always
called you Joe and Nancy."
>> "Then it's okay if we
just stay Joe and Nancy?"
>> "Perfectly okay.
Thank you, G.K., for all you
have done for our children."
>> Katherine Paterson:
"May I beg a small favor?"
>> "Certainly."
>> Katherine Paterson: "I
know it sounds preposterous,
but could I have one last
joke to send me on my way?"
>> M.T. Paterson: "Knock, knock."
>> Katherine Paterson:
"Who may I ask is calling?"
>> M.T. Paterson: "G.K."
>> Katherine Paterson: "G.K. who?"
>> M.T. Paterson: "Gee, Kan't you
stay with us a little longer?"
>> A fat tear rolled down
the porker's black snout.
>> Katherine Paterson: "Very good.
I almost wish I could, but
as you know, I must return."
>> M.T. Paterson: With that, he
waived a hoof and followed Roberta
through the door which
closed soundly behind them.
>> Katherine Paterson: Suddenly
Joe, who could never remain gloomy
for very long, whipped
something out of his pocket.
It was the birthday card that
had started all their adventures.
>> "Mom, Dad, when we got your
card, we were in the middle
of a really special birthday party."
>> "The Elephant Clown Party!
In all the excitement
I forgot about it.
>> "Yeah, yeah."
[ Screaming ]
>> "We didn't forget.
Come back to the tent.
Everything is ready.
We'll give you the
party of your lives."
>> M.T. Anderson: Now, we
don't have time to tell you
about the wonderful party.
You'll just have to use your
imagination to picture clowns
and elephants and seals and
lions and a bearded woman
and the headless woman and
monkeys and chimps and every person
and creature determined to give
the beloved twins the greatest time
of their eleven years, even
if in their hearts they knew
it was not only a birthday bash
but a farewell party.
>> Katherine Paterson: When it
was over, and Nancy and Joe turned
for the last worst goodbye to Hathi
and all their friends of the circus,
the loving pachyderm said
to the Sloppy parents:
>> "There's no need for you to go.
Please make your home with us."
>> "Joe and Nancy are
already family."
>> Katherine Paterson: The Senior
Sloppys looked at the twins and then
into the pleading eyes of every
person and beast assembled.
>> "Why not?
I could put my inventive
mind to work among you all."
>> "Why not?
I've always longed to ride
a bareback on elephants.
And I'm a terrible cook."
>> "Yeah, why not?
The villains are gone
and our parents are here.
That was all that was wrong with
the Sick and Tired Circus --
villains here and parents missing."
>> Katherine Paterson: Nancy
stroked the place on her arm
where the wolf had scratched her.
The house with a picket
fence and two parents
with their twins no
longer seemed so desirable.
Wasn't a circus the perfect
home for a girl who was,
at least for the present, part wolf?
And besides, she had promised
the wolves to speak out for them.
>> "Why not?"
>> Katherine Paterson:
Hathi encircled the four
Sloppys with her warm trunk.
>> "Then it's settled."
>> Katherine Paterson: I
won't say it was the end
of all their adventures, for Nancy
and Joe were an adventurous pair,
but it brings to a close the
Exquisite Corpse Adventure
>> Wow.
>> -- evil conquered, family united,
and friends who lived,
I'm quite sure
>> Happily ever after.
[ Applause ]
>> Good job, my boys.
>> Thank you, sir.
[ Laughter ]
>> Yo, Mary Brigid.
Nice job.
>> Mary Brigid: Thanks, Tim.
We actually finished before
we thought we were going to,
and it's so rare that kids
have so many distinguished
and talented authors and
illustrators on stage at one time.
Are there any questions
you would like to ask any
of our authors or illustrators?
Anybody? Yes.
Okay, this is the question.
And what's your name?
This is from Annie.
How did we get the story online?
Anybody want to answer that?
Oh, I can answer that.
>> John Cole: Perfect.
>> Mary Brigid: We got the story
online because as Mr. Cole,
Dr. Cole had mentioned, the
National Children's Book
and Literacy Alliance has
been working with the Center
for the Book for over 10 years.
We actually were the 10
o'clock event 10 years ago
at the very first National Book
Festival, so it's wonderful.
And we wanted to come
up with a great idea
that would get kids reading
and get kids writing,
and we thought the best way to do
that would be to create a wonderful,
whacky, entertaining story
that would last all year long.
And it's worked.
It's been quite successful, and
it's been a wonderful partnership.
So make sure you get to Read.gov.
And if you haven't read the
episodes, they are there for free.
>> How did we get the story online?
>> Mary Brigid: Oh, how did
we get the story online?
>> John Cole: We got
the story online.
It was through Mary Brigid.
>> Mary Brigid: Literally,
like literally how did
we get the story online?
Oh, my God.
Well, I guess that's a technical
>> Jeremy?
>> Mary Brigid: Yeah,
it's a technical question.
They wrote the episodes, and
then every two weeks we sent them
by computer to the
Library of Congress,
and the magical technology people at
the Library of Congress typed it all
up and got it right onto
the computer, like that.
We woke up every second
Friday morning
and there was a whole new episode
and a whole new illustration.
>> M.T. Anderson: People who haven't
seen it, it actually looks like a --
you can read it as a book.
It looks like a virtual
book on the Internet,
so you can actually read
it in sort of book format.
>> Timothy Basil Ering: When
you first get to that home page,
you'll see all the episodes listed
and who wrote them
and illustrated them.
And there's actually a part
where you can click onto hear it
and a part to click on to read it.
And when you do, you'll end
up at that virtual book,
and there's an arrow
where you can click
to go back and forth in the pages.
It's really well done.
And all the readers who read
the episodes are excellent,
beautifully read.
>> Mary Brigid: That was great, Tim.
You did much better than me.
All right, any, any
>> Timothy Basil Ering:
I was impressed with it.
>> Mary Brigid: Any other kids
have questions, you can walk right
up to one of the two
microphones in the aisles.
Be brave. Your mom and
dad are going to be
so proud if you ask a question.
Here comes somebody.
What's your first name?
>> Elizabeth: Elizabeth.
>> Mary Brigid: And where
are you from, Elizabeth?
>> Elizabeth: Virginia.
>> Mary Brigid: Virginia.
Elizabeth's from Virginia.
What's your question?
>> Elizabeth: I wondered
when we'll be able
to get the book of
the Exquisite Corpse.
>> Mary Brigid: When you'll
be able to get the book
for the Exquisite Corpse?
>> Elizabeth: Yeah,
when are you getting it?
>> Mary Brigid: I think
you'll be able to get the book
for the Exquisite Corpse
right here next year
at the National Book Festival.
>> Katherine Paterson:
So come back next year.
>> Mary Brigid: And just think,
we'll have all kinds of authors
and illustrators again,
and you can get tons
of their signatures all at one time.
>> It will also be in stores.
>> Mary Brigid: It will
also be in stores, yes.
>> And online as well.
>> Mary Brigid: And online as well,
and also if you don't
have it this year,
make sure you get those
posters at the back.
And you could take two posters.
Any of the kids can take two
posters -- one for their home,
and one to take to
school and show off
to their teacher when
they get there.
Any more? Oh, there's one over here.
Who are you?
>> Nell: Nell.
>> Mary Brigid: Nell?
>> Nell: Yeah.
I live in Massachusetts?
>> Yeah.
>> Mary Brigid: We
love Massachusetts.
>> Nell: My mom works in Boston.
>> Pardon?
>> Mary Brigid: In the
Cradle of Democracy.
>> Nell: Yeah.
But why didn't you just release
it as a book to start off with?
>> Mary Brigid: Why
didn't we release it
as a book to start off with?
Well, actually, a little
bit of history here.
There's a real famous author
that you'll be reading
soon named Charles Dickens,
and over 100 years ago, he got all
kinds of people reading by putting
up a book one episode at the time,
in what in those days was high
technology -- a newspaper.
And now, we did the same thing.
We put one episode up at a time,
and we've been building the audience
and building the audience 'til
I think Library of Congress,
we are averaging in some months
over 120,000 hits a month.
And that's just -- we figure
that a lot of those were teachers
and librarians who were going back
and sharing the book with the kids.
So our low-ball estimate
is that over 500,000,
possibly up to a million kids
around the world have been reading
the Exquisite Corpse episodes every
two weeks.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary Brigid: Any questions?
Oh, right over here.
>> Which episode was your favorite?
>> Mary Brigid: I'll
let the authors answer.
Which episode, other than your
own episode, was your favorite?
>> Katherine Paterson: Oh, food.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mary Brigid: Sorry, we'll
make it a little harder.
Tobin, did you have
a favorite episode?
>> M.T. Anderson: I loved the way
that John Scieszka
began the whole thing.
He just did a wonderful job.
He's
[ Applause ]
>> M.T. Anderson: Yeah.
He's not here, but yeah, he deserves
-- there was so much like energy
and enthusiasm in his episode that
we all were very inspired by it.
>> Katherine Paterson: I immediately
volunteered to do Chapter 2
because I thought, well, I know
John's first chapter's going
to be crazy and it's going
to get crazier and crazier,
so I want to get in fast
before it gets too crazy.
>> Mary Brigid: Linda Sue,
did you have a favorite?
>> Linda Sue: Well, I think that
Katherine had the hardest job.
It was a pretty unwieldy
package with lots of tentacles.
And she either wrapped them
neatly or just chopped them off.
And I so admire the way that
she got the last chapter
to pull everything together.
>> Mary Brigid: And Tim, Tim
and James both did a number
of illustrations for the episodes.
Which was your favorite episode
to illustrate, Tim and James?
>> Timothy Basil Ering: I think
the Cradle of Time was really --
the Cradle of Time was just
like -- that was written --
I loved every one of them.
And the Gingerbread House, the
door -- all of them were super fun,
but the Cradle of Time was
something just crazy and wild.
That was one of my
favorites, I think.
>> Mary Brigid: And
what about you, James?
>> James Ransome: I'm going to say
that first, it was just a pleasure
to work on all the
episodes that I worked on.
But I think the Lemony Snicket
episode was my favorite.
>> Mary Brigid: Yes, Lemony Snicket
wrote two of the episodes, too.
>> Yeah, which is really a lot
of fun, with the train crashes
and all the different things
that he put in that episode.
And it was just fun illustrating.
But they're all wonderful.
I still don't understand how the
writers can just sort of pick
up where someone else left off and
create these crazy -- it's insane.
A pig with a one eye
patch, the baby, the robot.
>> Mary Brigid: The pirate.
>> Arm-wrestling squid
or something like that.
I mean.
>> Mary Brigid: And I should say
that the reason we did this was --
the way we did it with, we want
us to repeat that kind of game
that you all play at home.
You've played it at camp.
You've played it on a stormy night.
You've played it when the lights
have gone out, if you live up north
and you get a winter
blackout, where one member
of the family starts a story and
stops at a cliff-hanging moment,
and then Aunt Margaret takes
up the next step, the next one,
and then Cousin Tommy does the next,
and then four-year-old
Benita does the next one.
And we wanted to keep
that spontaneity to it
so that pigs would feel free
to think, hey, this is a game
that we play, and we can
write like this, too.
That was a fabulous question.
Thank you so much.
We'll go over here.
What's your name?
>> Linda: Linda.
>> Mary Brigid: Linda,
what's your question?
>> Linda: How come you gather up
here to start a huge festival?
>> Mary Brigid: I'm sorry; Linda,
could you repeat that again?
>> Linda: How come
you come to Washington
and start up a huge festival?
>> Mary Brigid: How
come you all come
to Washington to this big festival?
Why do you do that?
>> Katherine Paterson:
Because it's so much fun.
>> Fun, fun, fun.
But did you ask how the
festival was started?
>> Mary Brigid: How the
festival was started.
I think John Cole, we'd have
to bring John Cole up to answer
that question, how the
festival got started?
Mr. Cole will be the expert
to give you that answer.
>> John Cole: The festival
was started,
came to us when Mrs. Laura Bush,
who was a reader and a librarian,
helped us start the first
book festival and had the idea
of bringing people together.
And we are now able, after
ten years, to keep this going
with the help of wonderful
groups like the ones
and performers that
you've just seen.
And we're very pleased to have
you all here, and let's close
with one final round of applause
for my friends, the performers
and the Exquisite Corpse Adventure.
>> Thank you.
Thanks a lot.
>> John Cole: You were
all wonderful,
and we will have one more
session a year from now
at the next book festival, when
we not only will bring back some
of the authors who have not
been part of the book festival,
but we will have the book for sale.
And as Mary Brigid said,
we can get it signed.
Thank you all very
much, and thank you.
[Applause]
>> Mary Brigid: Okay,
one more thing.
>> Thank you, thank you.
>> Mary Brigid: Those of you guys
that didn't get your
questions answered,
the autographing session
is from noon to 1 o'clock,
and if you have further questions,
I'm sure authors would be happy
to answer your questions then.
And also, if you want to have a
winning program, make sure you head
in that direction to
get your free copy
of our White House
Looking In Looking Out.
And it's also for sale
in the bookstore.
And lastly, get your Exquisite
Corpse poster and share it
with your friends at school and
your cousins and all your relatives,
and get grandma and grandpa reading
the Exquisite Corpse Adventure
with you, too.
Bye-bye. Have a great festival.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.
[ Silence ]